salve ho bevuto ruvide sono famiglie
oggi siamo su un pezzo di storia
videoludica è uscito finalmente dopo 15
anni non ha la più pallida idea il
quarto capitolo di crash bandicoot e per
me questo è un giorno da ricordare oggi
siamo al 2 marzo
no allo ragazzi siamo partiti brusco
risveglio non ho idea di niente perché
qua per me che io oggi non sarei qua se
non fosse questo gioco quindi grazie a
dio hanno fatto il 4 perché io me lo
farò 26 volte a prescindere se sia bello
brutto speriamo sia bello sei già
incassato non sembra anche parti vi è
grande tanto non mi ricordo non mi
ricordo ragazzi come finiva l'altro
trend però sicuramente una roba simile
rossi dentro vi sarà un fallimento di
nuovo al mio
ci proviamo da questa prigione
non starò qui un altro decennio non
ascoltare tutti i tuoi a 10 anni ci
rimarrò qui sono passati lì è il tempo
che è passato sul serio
ma è morto
lascialo ormai non ci serve più e morto
cauca è veramente morto un cauca per
farli evadere ma veramente mi chiede più
tristi iniziale pazzesco la parrocchia
il momento storico finale bello dove
questo dove abita cresce se questa è la
casa di crash bandicoot ragazzi
bellissima finissi non starò a mi sono
spaccato la chitarra checkmate di carini
allora bello però che c'è il minibar
c'è cresci tratti veramente bene
fratello per quale motivo ragazzi sto
gioco si preannuncia una figata totale
va bene di fare fare il tutorial giocato
gioco più di quanto sia andato a scuola
perché ne vada fiero aspetta ok allora
fuori dalle balle fuori dalle balle pure
tu grazie mi capo un bug va bene se non
sto capendo veramente se questo è un
tutorial o se effettivamente un livello
normale perché è fatto garante e hanno
mantenuto la l'esatta come si dice
l'esatto design di quello che era cresce
un tempo solo ovviamente con la grafica
di oggi ministra meglio io credo che
comunque cresce ragazzi sia uno dei
questo è uno dei giochi in assoluto che
negli anni non è mai in vecchie schifo
che negli anni non è mai invecchiato
credo che l'espresso stavo cercando di
dire un processo magno
non poteva anche evitare di metterlo
volevo dare 10 per adesso gioco viviamo
nove e mezzo mettete un altro segna ma 8
perfetto otto fratello giocato talmente
tanto che cosa è successo
sto dicendo ho giocato talmente tanto
che per me questo è uno scherzetto sono
che ha avuto però non ho capito perché
sa perché possono già dare la facciata
no perché negli altri crescita dovi
sbloccare ok non sapevo sono morto nel
tutorial signori bea posto che pensavo
che non si potesse dare la pancia doppio
satura di pace lo zio grazie madonna
rega ma cativo quindi così succede
dobbiamo raggiungere e missan i dei
problemi ciao ragazzi ho chiesto a gente
ma chi erano
cos'è oddio no rega bellissimo mi
ricordo un sacco tipo recente clienti
quando devi fare ste cose
se avete giocato alle celebri anche
sapevi che farlo presente ci sono stese
live di cose dove tu devi passare da una
corsia all'altra ma cosa nonostante in
crescere
a quanto pare si è figo e quindi va beh
mi rattrista perchè non potevi sbagliare
a fratello timida altro la la scala
panciata il doppio salto negli altri
clustering di bloccare cosa sbarcati
grazie a dio perché sia effettivamente
effettivamente tutti i giochi in tutti i
giochi c'è il doppio salto quindi mi
sembra giusto no no vabbè sto male puoi
vedere il primo sarà una cagata ragadi
bonus i bonus sono sempre sono la mia
parte preferita di crash bandicoot solo
che il primo immagino sia veramente lisi
ma mi sa che devo fare così guardano
no ho sbagliato non sarò mai
e invece ci arriva lo stesso che niente
scherza il di parma perché hanno messo
ste robe tipo poltronesofà ma cos'è
bellissimo in realtà sono sono dei
placement per i divani bellissimo strada
seconda auto va bene ragazzi però adesso
tutto ok
don est non ho visto niente di
particolarmente difficile parte in auto
nato lai l'invincibilità quando trovi
due gru bucap per me si chiama così
diventi vincibile io lo chiamo blu voga
perché da piccolo si chiamava ce l'ho
chiamato così perché effettivamente
conto lo prendi non dice
aku aku ma dice globo gas quindi per me
e bugatti è il centro perfetto sbaglia
meno male che è uscito alcun tempo dopo
senza lasciandole ma perché mi sento
abbastanza confide perfetto cosa che io
in genere quando succede poi cis piatto
che è una bellezza ma fa niente
non è vero
madonna che culo che culo finale meno
male da lei deve smetterla di
schiacciare cerchio quando
chiama piano il culo 97 su 104 potevo
fare molto meglio non sono stato a
prendere tutto quanto ragazzi sono
finiamo il video dopo domani posso anche
scegliere se cambiare mettere o cresce
la tizia e cambiare le skin di crash
ma veramente ma respingiamo questo uomo
technicolor
ma a rufus erectus potenziamento tosto o
gira e spara
no ragazzi vi prego ma cos'è no vabbè ma
sta morendo
vuoi cambiare aitchison le skin di crash
ma veramente bellissimo io metterei
potenziamento opposto perché mista di
figo doveva vedere a giocare con
potenziamento opposto perché non cambia
niente a livello di personaggio vero con
cambia solo madonna che ero vado alla
che tamarro il mio cresce così
bellissimo veramente da mar cambia mondo
[Musica]
mi è arrivato un subscriber in basso a
destra grazie mille garo non si è visto
niente prova se volete abbonarvi al
canale c'è il tasso passato ragazzi
allora non ho capito ma va bene
proseguiamo non è vero sono usate il
cervello quando giocate ai videogiochi
non come me che non ce lo devo ancora
capire quant'è la velocità con cui possa
fare sta roba perché sono riuscito ad
alzarmi premier grazie a napoli anche
oscillare no ma bernasco male veramente
quanta roba e puoi fare attaccato a sto
coso puoi fare di tutto praticamente ok
billo prima bonus cioè quello va beh
questa non l'ho capita ma chi se ne
frega bonus my friends rete è un mondo
fatto di monnezza volevo dire che ci
sono pneumatici scartati ovunque
finissimo e finissimo una teca però un
paletto
per cosa mi dice che è meglio levarsi
dalle balle yes che il giocatore non è
vero ma donavo rischiato tantissimo
perfetto come cacchio faccio a ok non
avevo capito ma va bene ma se provassi
tipo fare un livello con lei ragazzi
provo l'ultimo dai però voglio provare
con lei perché è la prima volta che puoi
switch aree personaggio c'è lo potevi
fare ma c'erano livelli proprio appositi
per la tipa adesso qua poi switch aree
personaggio quando vuoi prova usare lei
raga non sarà anche se le stesse se può
fare le stesse cose di crash secondo me
sì perché se no non avrebbe senso che
non potresti bene finire livelli al
cento per cento
concludiamo la per una volta facciamo
sto test cuore stessi speriamo sia anche
legale anno lei dalle culate letale
culate per terra va bene ragazzi sono
riuscito ad incastrarli in crash
bandicoot a ok se devi premuto va ancora
più sua che non sono io a dirlo come che
ho fatto chiusa a c'è anche scritto tv
premuto per rimbalzare pi in alto
ma manco leggere manco leggere veramente
mamma mia che culo finale e culo avuta
per ragazzi ma mi meritavo tantissimo di
morire non sono morto non so per quale
di giustizia divina
va bene provo a fare il bonus giusto
ragazzi almeno questo cos'è sta roba qua
che non c'è ma mi sa che lancia dovuto
mi blocco una cosa che mi fa tornare
indietro
e allora non le faccio fuori tutte
queste così tornò poi indietro credono
credo che mi farà tornare tutti dietro
perché a un certo punto di sblocchi
anche le altre cose non so quando ma
vabbè ecco qua adesso perfetto adesso
posso tornare indietro si sono attivate
le cose teoricamente figli 123 poi non
so come farò tornare ma fa niente quello
ci penso ok
allora questo ho trovato questo ho
trovato non so se riesco a tornare tutti
indietro ragazzi ma sarà fighissimo se
riuscirò sono i campioni che spendi che
ho fatto una roba incredibile cielo non
ci voglio credere
[Musica]